It was 25 years ago that my father found him.
He was torn to pieces and half-eaten.
Whatever did it...
...was big...
...and a buckshot couldn't kill it.
After that, my father went home and cast silver bullets.
And wouldn't leave the house on a full moon from then on.
Lo and behold, the prodigal son returns.
Hello, father.
You've come here for the funeral.
What happened?
Your brother's body was found on a ditch.
He'd been torn to pieces.
If there's anything you need, please let me know.
I want to know what happened to him.
Francis Abberline, Scotland Yard.
I cannot stress enough the mortal peril you're in.
What kind of animal could have done such a thing?
You're risking your life.
Darkness comes for you.
He's been quite seriously injured.
Thank you for staying with me.
Now we know it's still out there.
You were bitten by the beast.
You bear his mark now.
Do you believe in curses?
You have to leave.
What are you afraid of?
There are those who doubt the power to change men into beasts.
A beast has come among us.
Terrible things, Lawrence. You've done terrible things.
Be strong, son.
Be strong.
I am what they say I am.
I'm a monster.
I will kill all of you.
Let me help you.
The beast will have its day.